je rappelle que je donnerai d'abord la
parole au ministre pour 10 minutes puis
un autre rapporteur pierre d'arriville
pour 10 minutes également viendront
ensuite les orateurs des groupes
politiques pour 5 minutes chacun leur
apporteur spécial de la commission des
finances Dominique Da Silva pour deux
minutes les autres questions pour une
minute chacune et je serai braconnière
je vous remercie par avance de bien
vouloir veiller au respect de ces temps
de parole car nous devons ensuite
laisser le ministre répondre et après
son départ examiner les 34 amendements
dont la Commission a été saisie monsieur
le ministre je vous donne immédiatement
la parole merci madame la Présidente
Monsieur rapporteur monsieur rapporteur
spécial quelques mots pour présenter ce
budget relatif à la mission travail
d'abord pour dire en introduction que ce
budget porte en réalité et c'est très
naturel les crédits qui permettent la
mise en oeuvre des 8 priorités de la
feuille de route que j'ai eu l'occasion
de présenter devant vous le 13 septembre
c'est la volonté donc de poursuivre un
objectif de plein emploi c'était
explique que le budget que je défends
devant vous s'élève à 20 milliards 900
millions d'euros
en autorisation d'engagement et
20,9 milliards d'euros en crédit de
paiement je précise d'emblée que la
marche extrêmement importante entre 2022
et 2023 auteur de 6,2 milliards d'euros
de crédit de paiement s'explique très
largement par des questions de périmètre
puisque un certain nombre de
dispositions qui étaient financés par le
plan de relance je pense au prime à
l'apprentissage je pense à une partie de
l'activité partielle font l'objet
désormais d'un financement en droit
commun et lorsque l'on regarde des
choses qui sont comparables nous sommes
sur une augmentation d'environ un
milliard un milliard d'euros en
autorisation d'engagement et un milliard
100 en crédit de paiement ce milliard
correspond grossièrement à la dynamique
de compensation des exonérations de
cotisations pour un peu plus de 600
millions d'euros et c'est lié aussi au
nombre de créations d'emplois de l'année
2022 et de ce que nous espérons en 2023
cela correspond aussi à l'inscription de
350 millions d'euros au titre à la fois
du Front national Pôle Emploi le FNE
pour la partie formation j'y reviendrai
mais aussi le financement auteur de 50
millions d'euros des dispositifs de
transition collective et avec quelques
autres le dispositif plus accessoires en
montant cela explique ce milliard
différence à périmètre constant ce
budget illustre si je crois un des
résultats de la politique d'emploi mener
depuis un an et de la politique de
l'emploi menait depuis plusieurs années
je dis un an car depuis un an nous avons
mis en place un plan de réduction des
tensions de recrutement qui a permis de
d'accompagner vers l'emploi ou de
raccompagner à la fois 380000 demandeurs
d'emploi au niveau national mais parmi
eux 280 000 emplois demandeurs d'emploi
pardon de longue durée et 146 000
demandeurs d'emploi de très longue durée
et cette diminution de 146 000 du nombre
de demandeurs d'emploi de très longue
durée explique le principalement à la
baisse de ce budget qui porte sur des
crédits de l'allocation spéciale de
Spécifique de Solidarité en baisse de
8492 millions d'euros mais cela
correspond en réalité à la diminution du
nombre de bénéficiaires par retour à
l'emploi de demandeur d'emploi de très
longue durée il y a un certain nombre de
priorités qui sont donc financés avec ce
budget d'abord le maintien d'une
priorité très forte en matière de
soutien à l'alternance et à
l'apprentissage avec le maintien de
prime important en matière d'embauche
d'apprenti nous travaillons avec Carole
Grandjean un ministre délégué pour faire
en sorte que le montant des aides à
l'embauche en 2023 permettent de
garantir la dynamique tout en revenant
progressivement à des niveaux de
dépenses plus soutenable il s'agit aussi
de soutenir France compétences donc
la santé financière a pu être dégradée
par l'augmentation très importante du
nombre de contrats portés je disais nous
avons la volonté aussi de continuer à
agir en matière en matière de soutien à
la formation et la principale nouveauté
si je puis dire ce dispose de ce texte
budgétaire que je vous présente consiste
en inscription en droit commun de 350
millions d'euros au titre du FN de
formation et des dispositifs de
transition collective sachant qu'ils
étaient jusqu'à présent financés dans le
cadre du plan de relance nous avons
voulu enfin c'est la troisième priorité
que je veux souligner concentrer nos
efforts sur celles et ceux qui sont les
plus éloignés de l'emploi cela passe par
quelques dizaines de millions d'euros
inscrits à titre expérimental pour
accompagner la structuration de France
travail pour accompagner aussi
l'amélioration de l'accompagnement des
bénéficiaires du RSA dans un certain
nombre de territoires d'expérimentation
que nous allons prochainement désigner
cela passe surtout par le maintien de
deux outils à des niveaux très
importants de trois outils pardon à des
niveaux très importants d'abord le pic
le plan le programme d'investissement
dans les compétences qui est maintenu à
un niveau de 2,5 milliards d'euros 1,6
milliard d'euros pour financer le volet
régional conformément aux engagements
que nous avions pris 800 millions
d'euros au niveau national pour financer
des actions de formation qui ont une
portée nationale comme je l'indiquais à
l'instant et 100 millions d'euros en
matière de pic spécifique un insertion
par l'activité économique je tiens à
préciser que pour ce qui concerne
l'insertion par l'activité économique et
ça fait le lien avec le deuxième point
que je voulais aborder c'est une
augmentation de 25% du pic IAE qui
permet donc de garantir un meilleur
accès à la formation de celle et ceux
qui sont salariés d'entreprises
d'insertion de structures d'insertion
par activité économique considérant que
au-delà de l'activité la formation
évidemment essentielle pour ce qui
concerne l'insertion par l'activité
économique nous vous présentons un
budget en hausse budget en hausse pour
tenir le cap du plan pour du plan
ambition pour l'inclusion qui avait été
annoncé par le président de la
République en 2019 ainsi les critiques
nous vous proposons d'adopter permettent
de financer une augmentation de 7000 ETP
supplémentaires en structure d'insertion
pour passer de 88000 ETP réalisés en
2022 à 95000 l'année prochaine et je
précise que cette augmentation du nombre
de TP et les budgets qui sont en
augmentation pour l'accompagner inclut
aussi la prison compte de l'augmentation
du SMIC de façon à ce que cette
revalorisation du SMIC ne pèse
évidemment pas sur la trésorerie les
finances des structures d'insertion par
l'activité économique notre objectif est
le suivant nous souhaitons atteindre en
2025 122000 ETP en insertion ce qui
correspondra à 240 000 personnes
bénéficiaires à l'échelle d'une année
puisque les contrats d'insertion étant
faudra attendre partielle il y a cette
clé qui fait que pour 122000 et PP nous
atteindrons 240 000 personnes
je tiens à préciser qu'en matière
d'insertion par l'activité économique
nous avons aussi fait le choix dans une
première version de ce budget je dis
première version car ça renvoie à des
questions de pilotage tout au long de
l'année de vouloir porter pousser les
places disponibles à la fois dans les
entreprises d'insertion et dans les
entreprises de travail temporaires
d'insertion cela relève d'une volonté
d'améliorer à nos yeux en tout cas le
mix avec les différentes structures les
différentes places mais tout ça doit
être affiné au cours de l'année pardon
grâce à un pilotage que nous souhaitons
plus précis des crédits que nous vous
proposons
pardonnez-moi le troisième objectif qui
est maintenu et qui est fort à nos yeux
concernent l'accès des jeunes à l'emploi
et donc nous vous proposons de
renouveler en 2023 les crédits qui
permettent d'atteindre 300 signatures de
300 000 contrats d'engagement jeune 200
000 portées par l'émission locale 100
000 portées par Pôle emploi pour l'année
2022 nous avons largement franchi le cap
des 200 000 nous pensons nous
terminerons l'année autour de 280 000
contrat signés ce qui est pour une
première année débuté au 1er mars un bon
résultat c'est la traduit à la fois par
l'inscription de presque 1,8 milliards
d'euros de crédit pour financer la
totalité du contrat engagement jeune à
la fois l'accompagnement mais aussi les
allocations versées au bénéficiaires et
ça se traduit de manière plus indirecte
par l'inscription de crédit à hauteur de
630 millions d'euros un peu plus au
bénéfice des missions locales dans le
cadre du soutien accru par définition
que l'État apporte à ces structures
enfin en matière d'accompagnement des
publics les plus éloignés de l'emploi je
veux dire un mot des crédits que nous
souhaitons consacrer en 2023 aux
entreprises adaptées pour les personnes
en situation de handicap puisque ces
crédits vont passer de 465 à 495
millions d'euros pour nous permettre là
aussi de tenir les trajectoires à la
fois de prise en compte de la
ravalorisation du SMIC et d'augmentation
du nombre de places j'ai indiqué tout à
l'heure que ce budget permettait de
tenir compte et de financer la dynamique
de la dynamique de la compensation des
exonérations de cotisations portées par
cette mission je voudrais simplement
terminer par trois points le premier
pour dire que à travers ce budget nous
avons aussi prévu de financer un nombre
significatif d'emplois aidés des emplois
francs dans un montant et un volume
pendant un volume seulement aimer pour
un montant identique un peu inférieur à
celui de 2022 considérant que nous
avions en 2021 en 2022 porté à un niveau
très élevé le nombre d'emplois francs
pour faire face aux conséquences de la
crise et que nous sortons de cette
dynamique du plan de relance nous
faisons le choix de vous proposer le
financement d'un peu plus de 31 500
contrats d'insertion économique donc des
contrats aidés dans le secteur privé
c'est moins qu'en 2022 mais dans une
période où nous rencontrons des tensions
de recrutement il nous paraît logique
d'avoir moins de contrats dans le
secteur économique privé par contre nous
vous proposons d'inscrire le financement
de 80 000 pecs les contrats aidés du
secteur public c'était 67000 en 2022
nous avions complété ces 67000 par 10000
postes supplémentaires au cours de l'été
2022 pour arriver à 77000 et nous
proposons ainsi de débuter l'année 2023
avec 80000 pecs inscrit dans le PDF 2023
avant dernier point que je souhaite
évoquer devant vous très rapidement pour
dire que les crédits du ministère sont
portés par quelques programmes que les
programmes que j'ai évoqués sont des
programmes extrêmement conséquents mais
qu'il y a un programme le programme 111
qui concerne les questions de qualité de
vie au travail qui méritent aussi de
l'attention même si les sommes sont
moins importantes nous augmentons ces
crédits de 28% ça concerne cela
représente quelques dizaines de millions
d'euros et c'est la mise en œuvre
des dispositions votées par le Parlement
à l'occasion de l'adoption de la Loi sur
la santé au travail d'août 2021 pour
accompagner les services de prévention
et de santé au travail dernier mot sur
les moyens dont dispose le ministère et
son principal opérateur Pôle Emploi
d'abord pour dire que la subvention
versée par l'État à Pôle Emploi va
augmenter de 133 millions d'euros que la
contribution d'une édit qu'au
financement de Pôle Emploi va aussi
augmenter d'environ 400 millions d'euros
du fait la dynamique de la masse
salariale et si nous comparons sur une
période de 5 ans Pôle Emploi dispose de
moyens en augmentation d'environ entre 3
millions d'euros entre pardonnez-moi
je pardonnais moi je fais une confusion
Pôle emploi en tout cas dispose de
moyens nettement plus conséquents entre
2017 et 2022 je reviendrai sur le
chiffre dans un instant et dispose
d'environ 3000 équivalentes en plein
supplémentaires par rapport à 2017 pour
accompagner les différentes politiques
mises en œuvre pour ce qui concerne le
ministère lui-même le ministère du
Travail à périmètre constant a connu un
schéma d'emploi à la baisse pendant 10
ans avec 180 suppressions d'emplois par
an nous vous proposons d'inverser la
tendance avec la création de 60 emplois
nets en 2023 indépendamment des mesures
temporaires que nous avions mises en
place pour accompagner la nouvelle
organisation territoriale de l'État et
la mise en place de l'activité de
l'activité partielle et c'est 60 emplois
nous permettront à la fois de mieux
préparer les Jeux Olympiques en matière
droit du travail mais aussi
d'accompagner le développement de la
direction générale de l'emploi et de la
formation professionnelle ainsi que
l'internalisation d'un certain nombre
d'activités qui jusqu'à présent était
confiés à des cabinets de conseils et
que nous souhaitons pouvoir exercer en
c'est l'objectif de ces créations
d'emploi voilà madame la Présidente et
si vous me permettez je reviendrai tout
à l'heure sur les moyens de Pôle emploi
puisque je me suis moi-même perdu dans
les chiffres que je voulais donner à la
commission des affaires sociales merci
de cet exercice de 10 minutes et puis
vous avez le droit chère ministre de
vous désaltérer maintenant monsieur
d'arriver la bouffe
si madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre monsieur le rapporteur spécial
chers et chers collègues nous ne savons
pas si le Parlement sera autorisé très
longtemps par le gouvernement à discuter
les contenus du projet de loi de finance
qui intervient dans un contexte
d'inflation persistante et de défi
considérable pour le travail et l'emploi
qu'à cela tienne profitons du moment
présent je voudrais commencer par
quelques remarques générales sur la
mission travailler emploi dont la hausse
doit être relativisée d'une part elle
était très attendue pour assurer le
financement de tous les objectifs
d'autant plus dans ce contexte
d'inflation et vous venez d'indiquer
monsieur le ministre qu'elle était aussi
le fait de la dynamique des exonérations
de cotisation ce qui est de mon point de
vue donne à réfléchir et d'autre part
elle est largement le fait de la
disparition du programme cohésion de la
mission plan de relance les crédits du
programme 102 accès et retour à l'emploi
sont toutefois en diminution à contrario
de la dynamique observée l'an passé le
gouvernement explique que cette
diminution est due à l'amélioration de
la situation permettez-moi de trouver
cette très hasardeuse un fort Fiori au
regard de la réforme de l'assurance
chômage en cours d'adoption qui aura
pour effet des fins de droit plus
précoces un rebours de la tendance
constatée sur l'ensemble du précédent
quinquennat le montant des crédits
versés à Pôle emploi au titre de la
subvention pour charge de service public
augmente rappelons toutefois que ce
n'est qu'un léger rattrapage au regard
du reflux de la part de l'État dans le
financement de Pôle emploi et le
gouvernement entend diminuer le plafond
d'emploi de l'opérateur ce qui m'amène à
une première question comment justifier
nos nouvelles baisses qui aura
nécessairement des effets préjudiciables
sur les conditions de travail des
salariés de Pôle emploi alors que vous
annoncez dans le même temps une
reconfiguration du service public de
l'emploi qui appelle un renforcement la
hausse des crédits du programme 103 est
très largement porté par le rapatriement
des crédits dédiés à l'activité
partielle et qui figurait auparavant
dans la mission plan de relance ce
programme finance également la
validation des acquis de l'expérience
sur je m'étonne monsieur le ministre que
la dotation d'un million d'euros prévu
soit constante alors que vous venez
d'engager au beauté une réforme visant à
donner de l'ampleur la vaae comment
comptez-vous assurer son financement en
2023 concernant les crédits du programme
111 amélioration de la qualité de
l'emploi et des relations de travail je
souhaiterais que Monsieur le Ministre
puisse apporter également quelques
précisions sur l'utilisation concrète
qui a été faite des crédits de l'action
renforcement de la prévention en santé
au travail en 2022 enfin dans le
programme 115 155 pardon conception
gestion évaluation des politiques de
l'emploi du travail les crédits dédiés à
la communication bondise de 3,4 millions
après de 10 millions d'euros soit
quasiment plus de 100%, pourquoi ne
penser ou pas monsieur le ministre
d'autres actions de ce programme
auraient mérité une telle augmentation
je pense par exemple au crédit destiné à
la DARES dont les travaux dans un monde
du travail en mutation profonde son
précieux pouvez-vous au passage nous
indiquer si votre ministère envisage
d'avoir recours à des cabinets de
conseils pour quelle mission et pour
quel montant
je veux à présent braquer le projecteur
sur un premier thème celui du service
public de l'emploi dans un contexte de
réforme annoncé France travail est un
objet encore très flou si un
préfigurateur a été nommé pour préparer
sa mise en place dès 2024 les différents
acteurs auditionnés ne disposent
d'éléments précis sur son périmètre et
sur son contenu il souligne les efforts
déjà entreprises dans le rapprochement
des différents acteurs du service public
de l'emploi donc France travail semble
être le prolongement mais quel est le
diagnostic et que peut-on dire de
l'ensemble des objectifs poursuivis sans
parler de la forme juridique que prendra
France travail les enjeux sont multiples
par exemple quid des jeunes les plus
éloignés qui ont besoin de
remobilisation et affronte des
problématiques dites périphériques rien
n'est aujourd'hui fléché pour financer
des solutions et les missions locales
ont trop peu de leviers à leurs mains
autre sujet il faudrait évaluer les
effets des financements publics de
l'insertion entre un éparpillement des
fonds d'un côté et le financement de
Major de l'insertion de l'autre cette
réforme interroge d'autant plus que la
préfiguration se déroule sur le même
calendrier que la remasterisation de
assurance chômage par laquelle l'État la
dénature et accroît sa main mise sur la
gouvernance elle comprend un volet
système d'information et pourquoi pas
mais qui pourrait faire rêver les
tenants d'une logique adéquationniste et
court thermiste ma question monsieur le
ministre comment garantirez-vous au
privé d'emploi le respect de leur
parcours et de leur choix professionnel
dans le nouveau service public de
l'emploi que vous essayez de dessiner il
est d'ailleurs révélateur que la seule
mention de France travaille dans le PLF
soit lié à une expérimentation de 20
millions d'euros destinés à mettre en
oeuvre dans une dizaine de bassins de
villes accompagnement mais aussi le
contrôle accru des allocataires du RSA
qui devront s'engager à 15 à 20h de
suivi sans qu'on en sache beaucoup plus
à ce stade on peut se demander quelle
articulation avec le dispositif
territoire zéro chômeurs et avec les
ateliers et chantiers d'insertion par
exemple qui voient leur plafond et TP BC
de 6%, alors qu'il leur avait été
annoncé une augmentation et d'ailleurs
au passage monsieur le ministre vous
avez annoncé des chiffres sur l'IAE qui
ne me semble pas vraiment lisible dans
le budget tel que tel que je l'ai lu
atelier chantier d'insertion j'y reviens
qui accueille 52% de bénéficiaires du
RSA je m'interroge monsieur le ministre
sur le champ exact de cette
expérimentation puis de sa prompte
généralisation concernera-t-elle tous
les allocataires du RSA y compris ceux
durablement éloignés de l'emploi ici oui
quelle forme prendra cette nouvelle
obligation j'en viens maintenant au
second thème la situation de
l'inspection du travail et prouvé par
une quinzaine d'années de transformation
elle traverse une prise profonde cette
crise est d'abord une crise de sens en
plusieurs occasions le ministère a été
critiqué pour son défaut de soutien à
ses agences ces dernières années il a
également accentué la case du Code du
travail qui fonde leur intervention
d'autre part c'est à se demander s'il
affaiblissement de l'inspection du
travail n'allait pas de père avec ses
réformes alors que le travail lui-même
est en crise tant il est trop souvent
maltraité et gâché nous avons besoin
d'une inspection du travail forte pour
faire respecter le travail et celles et
ceux qui travaillent évoquant
l'organisation territoriale de
l'inspection d'abord premièrement les
unités de contrôle créées par le plan
ministère fort n'ont pas réellement
trouvé leur place pas plus que leur
responsable les ruques que
l'administration a peiné à recruter et à
former de son côté le plan de
transformation des contrôleurs en
inspecteurs du travail pose question
Quels sont les perspectives offertes ou
contrôleur jusqu'à l'extinction de leur
corps d'appartenance deuxièmement le
redécoupage des sections de contrôle
engendré un sentiment d'isolement chez
les agents et troisièmement l'inspection
du travail fait les frais de la réforme
relative à l'organisation territoriale
de l'État et de la mutualisation des
moyens entre les directions
interministérielles qu'elles entraîne
matériel insuffisant les équipements de
protection individuel par exemple ou mal
entretenu les véhicules de service
Ressources Documentaires indisponibles
etc or les crédits de fonctionnement des
services déconcentrés de l'État
n'augmente que de 2% dans le PLF pour
2023 et ses crédits je le sais relève
d'une mission portée par le ministère de
l'intérieur mais si des fois n'est pas
accentué il y a peu de chances que ces
difficultés concrètes pour
l'accomplissement des missions de
l'inspection du travail se résorbent
monsieur le ministre je souhaite savoir
si le gouvernement réfléchit a de
nouvelles évolutions sur l'organisation
de l'inspection le travail je souhaite
aussi que vous puissiez nous renseigner
sur le contenu du rapport de l'Igas
traitant de la question des ruques qui
n'a pas été rendu public à ce jour pour
une raison que j'ignore en ce qui
concerne les priorités hiérarchiques de
l'action d'inspection du travail ensuite
il apparaît nécessaire que leur nombre
soit limité et que les personnels soient
davantage associés à leur définition
j'ajoute que la politique du chiffre qui
affecte toute la fonction publique
constitue un poids contre-productif elle
devrait être allégée selon la direction
générale du travail enfin l'inspection
du travail souffre d'un manque de moyens
humains très préoccupant entre fin 2017
et mars 2022 le nombre d'agents chargés
du contrôle des entreprises à diminuer
de 250 TP les services de renseignement
se vident de leurs effectifs et les
assistants de contrôle auraient perdu le
tiers des leurs en disant sur le terrain
ce manque de moyens se traduit par un
fort taux de poste vacant au sein des
actions de contrôle qui atteindraient
15% dans le pays en moyenne cette
situation empêche l'inspection du
travail de remplir ses missions en
certains endroits du territoire et créer
des rupture d'égalité ce à quoi la
suppression de section non pourvue ne
change rien il faut impérativement
intensifier les recrutements
d'inspecteur d'assistant de contrôle
d'agent changé du renseignement
l'augmentation du volume des postes
offerts au recrutement d'inspecteurs par
voie de concours ne résoudra rien si le
ministère du travail ne parvient pas à
rendre à la profession plus attractive
pour cela au moins deux grandes actions
doivent être engagées d'abord une
augmentation des rémunérations des
personnels je crois savoir qu'une
enveloppe de 2,5 millions d'euros est
prévu à cet effet je souhaiterais
monsieur le ministre que vous puissiez
le confirmer à la Commission et indiquer
le montant moyen des hausses de
traitement à venir et leur modalités de
distribution ensuite une meilleure
promotion des métiers dans le
prolongement des initiatives déjà
lancées
pour ce qui est la deuxième grande
action qui pourrait être engagée et
enfin une troisième qui pourrait être de
stopper la dérégulation permanente du
travail et d'afficher une volonté du
droit du travail et d'afficher une
volonté politique forte en faveur du
respect de celles et ceux qui
travaillent et de leur travail pour
conclure je souhaiterais que monsieur le
ministre vous puissiez indiquer à la
Commission le montant des crédits
affectés à l'inspection du travail en
2023 et leur évolution l'extinction du
travail a besoin de retrouver de
l'indépendance et de la force
si Monsieur Dary
nous allons venir maintenant au orateurs
de groupe politique je vous rappelle
pour 5 minutes chacun donc pour le
groupe Renaissance Monsieur Didier Le
Gac
merci madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Ministre chers collègue bien la mission
après et formation du PLF revêt cette
année une importance stratégique majeure
puisque vous le savez tous elle
s'inscrit dans l'objectif du
gouvernement de viser au plein emploi à
cette occasion il est c'est le moment de
rappeler qu'au moment nous examinons les
crédits de cette mission les chiffres du
chômage qui depuis longtemps n'ont
jamais été aussi bas j'amène Le Pen
emploi a paru aussi atteignable
qu'aujourd'hui les chiffres sont aussi
bas depuis au moins 15 ans je tenais
vraiment le rappeler à nous en réjouir
notamment pour tous ceux qui comme moi
ont vécu depuis des décennies avec un
chômage de masse
c'est donc une logique c'est donc dans
cette logique d'atteindre du plaid
emploi que cette mission poursuit son
effort financier c'est indéniable en
faveur de l'emploi et de la formation
professionnelle avec une eau de son
budget de 4,5 milliards d'euros en
autorisation d'engagement et 6,2 en
crédit de paiement soit un montant total
de 20,3 milliards en autorisation
d'engagement et 20,9 milliards d'euros
en crédit de paiement des jamais atteint
comme les cris notre rapporteur le
projet de loi de finance 2022 pour 2023
consacre donc une hausse réelle de
moyens à cette mission or plan de
relance les hauts de crédit pour cette
mission concerne également les aides en
faveur du développement de l'alternance
avec 3,5 milliards la dotation en France
compétente avec 1,7 milliards et la
poursuite des pactes régionaux
d'investissement dans les compétences
financées pour moitié par des crédits
budgétaires jamais autant de crédit pour
l'insertion par l'aide économique l'IAE
pour la formation professionnelle pour
l'alternance n'avait été débloqué c'est
bien évidemment une excellente nouvelle
concernant les emplois aidés Infocus
pour dire d'abord que le dispositif a
donc été modifié en 2018 je m'en
félicite souvenez-vous en 2017 nous
étions à presque un demi million
d'employés dans notre pays lorsque nous
sommes arrivés d'ailleurs pour la
plupart ils n'étaient pas financé et
n'offrait il faut le dire aucune
perspective réelle ni de pérennité de
leur emploi ni d'évolution au sein de
l'entreprise pour ces jeunes qui en
était bénéficiaires aujourd'hui en
revanche en 2023 donc s'ils ont été
recentrés pardon en 2018 autour de
l'objectif premier d'insertion
professionnelle et bien en 2023 ils sont
augmentés le ministre vient de le
rappeler et notamment pour la sphère
publique ou 80.000 contrats seront
possibles et notamment au sein et au
bénéfice des collectivités toriales et
là aussi je mens félicite le 2023
permettra le démarrage d'action
préfigurant de que sera France travail
ainsi que les expérimentations en faveur
de l'insertion des allocataires du
Revenu de Solidarité Active concernant
le programme 102 il vise trois objectifs
majeurs toujours dans le souci de
favoriser le retour à l'emploi le
premier favoriser l'accès le retour à
l'emploi le deuxième améliorer
l'efficacité du service rendu aux
usagers par Pôle Emploi le troisième
mobilisé au mieux les outils d'insertion
professionnelle en faveur de nos
concitoyens l'exercice 2023 sera marqué
par la poursuite et l'amélioration des
mesures pour l'emploi des jeunes dans la
continuité du plan un jeune 1 soluce une
solution qui a permis à 4 millions de
jeunes de trouver soit un emploi soit
une formation soit un parcours
d'insertion notamment dans le cadre du
contrat d'engagement jeune la
mobilisation du réseau des missions
locales
continuera en 2023 toujours dans le
programme 102 il convient de souligner
aussi la politique menée en direction
des personnes les plus éloignées du
marché du travail le fond d'inclusion
dans l'emploi le fie regroupant les
emplois d le dispositif d'insertion par
l'activité économique et des gros mots
d'employeurs pour l'insertion et la
qualification les geeks se voient ainsi
confortés concernant l'expérimentation
territoriale je souhaite rappeler ici
parce qu'il y a eu beaucoup de débats
encore aujourd'hui que le dispositif
d'expérimentation territoire zéro
chômeur de longue durée destiné à ceux
qui sont le plus éloignés du travail est
bien prolongé et bénéficie bien d'une
participation de l'État pour 2023 de
44,94 millions en autorisation
d'engagement et crédits de paiement
enfin toujours sur le programme 102
notons les mesures de l'emploi des
personnes handicapées qui s'élèvent à
517 milliards on autorisation
d'engagement et crédit de paiement
concernant le programme 103 maintenant
accompagnement des mutations économiques
et développement de l'emploi il vise à
soutenir les actifs et les entreprises
dans leur phase de transition et leur
montée en compétence des crédits de
paiement 12,6 milliards contre 6
milliards pour la loi de finances 2022
la principale hausse vous le savez
concerne bien évidemment le soutien au
développement des contrats
d'apprentissage et de
professionnalisation enfin qu'on vient
de souligner c'est le programme 111 que
la protection de la santé des salariés
renforcée avec la mise en oeuvre de la
réforme de la santé au travail
issus comme vous le savez de la loi que
nous avons votée en 2021 les questions
de santé au travail demeurent donc à ce
titre au coeur du PLF 2023 regarde
l'importance de ce sujet la pandémie de
du covid et ses conséquent nous en ont
rappelé l'importance si besoin il en
était merci à tous merci Monsieur le
gars que pour le rassemblement national
monsieur marcchio merci merci
la présidente monsieur le ministre
permettez-moi de m'interroger sur
l'utilité de cette audition monsieur le
ministre votre gouvernement s'apprête à
activer l'article 49-3 sur le PDF à
rejeté la majorité des amendements que
nous députés avons voté pour nous
retenir que ceux qui lui plaisent une
nouvelle fois c'est le signe d'un
profond mépris de la macronie à l'égard
du Parlement et donc de la volonté du
peuple et en participant à cette
audition aujourd'hui je me pose la
question je pense aussi avec l'ensemble
de mes collègues à quoi bon débattre vu
que vous décidez de tout avec votre
minorité parlementaire la question du
travail et de l'emploi et pourtant
fondamental elle mériterait un peu plus
d'humilité et d'écoute de votre part
vous vous félicitez régulièrement des
bons chiffres du chômage pourtant à
l'image des habitants du Nord qui m'ont
élu je doute qu'il y ait de quoi se
vanter
au-delà de vos chiffres la réalité de
nombreux territoires comme le mien c'est
un chômage endémique lié à une
désindustrialisation et des
délocalisations désastreuses imposées
par votre idéologie ultralibérale et
mondialiste
9,4% de chômeurs dans les hauts de
France Monsieur le Ministre 9,4 deux
points de plus que la moyenne nationale
et nous ne parlons que de demandeurs
d'emploi de catégorie A pour cette
France qui souffre que faites-vous au
juste
ce projet de loi de finance est une
illustration d'une non-sens de votre
politique
nous le savons tous la difficulté de
retrouver un emploi et proportionnelle
au temps passé au chômage c'est
particulièrement vrai dans mon
département où le taux de demandeur
d'emploi de longue durée est élevée les
services d'aide et assez public en
grande difficulté devrait voir leurs
moyens renforcer mais vous faites tout
le contraire puisque dans le programme
102 vous diminuez de 9,2 % les
autorisations d'engagement et crédit de
paiement alloué à l'amélioration de
l'efficacité du service de l'emploi
quelle cohérence concernant France
travail projet phare du président de la
République au-delà du marketing autour
d'un nouvel outil c'est le flou article
artistique qui règne pardon le
rapprochement entre Pôle emploi et Cap
Emploi favorise certes l'accompagnement
des personnes handicapées et c'est à
saluer mais le cycle des concertations
qui s'est ouvert depuis septembre laisse
profondément dubitatif les partenaires
sociaux le secrétaire général de la CFTC
cité par le journal Le Monde déclare
d'ailleurs on a l'impression navigue à
vue si tu n'habitue chez vous en l'état
le risque est réel que France travaille
ne soit qu'un gadget au mieux un outil
qui dégrade l'existant au pire vous mes
estimez l'importance d'avoir des
personnels bien formés motivés et
confiant dans leur propre avenir
professionnel comment comptez-vous aider
les publics les plus fragiles
si vous précarisez déjà ceux qui leur
viennent en aide dans certaines agences
de Pôle Emploi jusqu'à 50% des personnes
accompagnant les demandeurs d'emploi
seraient en CDD ces personnes sont
dotées d'outils informatiques qui visent
moins s'adapter aux réalités humaines
des demandeurs d'emploi mais plus à
produire des statistiques et à faire
rentrer des gens les gens dans dans des
catégories dans des cases dans des
secteurs de recherche d'emploi définis
par des algorithmes les chiffres avant
la qualité des services et dans ces
conditions les personnels du service
public de l'emploi ont bien du mérite à
accomplir avec des mouvements leur
mission nous espérons au moins que pour
la mise en place de cette nouvelle
structure vous aurez recours à
l'intelligence et la compétence des
personnels de grande qualité qui
travailleront et non à des cabinets de
conseils les cinq dernières années votre
gouvernement a littéralement gavé ces
cabinets qui interviennent à des prix
exorbitants pour des prestations souvent
hors sol
quand on voit les dégâts que certaines
de leurs propositions ont causé à
l'hôpital public par exemple il y a de
quoi de craindre le pire d'autant que
ces gabinets sont déjà extrêmement bien
implantés chez les opérateurs de
l'emploi et qu'ils y font du chiffre en
tout état de cause vous avez déjà exclu
député et sénateurs des travaux initiés
depuis septembre 2022 alors que tous ici
quel que soit nos groupes politiques
nous connaissons intimement la réalité
de nos territoires pour être confrontés
à la misère économique et sociale chaque
jour comme je le disais en début de mon
propos c'est le signe d'approfond mépris
pour ce Parlement et je doute que
l'audition de ce jour nous apporte hélas
des réponses concrètes merci monsieur le
ministre
monsieur Stéphane Viry pour les
républicains merci merci madame la
Présidente je voudrais en tout premier
lieu salut le rapport pour ravi de notre
collègue Pierre d'arriville notamment
dans son analyse des crédits affichés
dans cette mission son avis relève me
semble-t-il des interrogations légitimes
sur les moyens réels donnés à la
politique de l'emploi et aux solutions
de mise en situation professionnelle ce
ministre je vous donne acte des éléments
portés à notre connaissance et des
nuances de compréhension à intégrer pour
apprécier la réalité des données
budgétaires c'est important la parole
publique quand elle cherche à être
crédible aux yeux de tes relations que
nous pouvons avoir avec nos concitoyens
je souhaite que les administrations
centrales en général et également cette
même exigence de célérité
et de sincérité lorsque nous devons
avoir des rapports avec eux ça me parait
ça me paraît important pour revenir sur
le volume des crédits et sur les
interrogations qu'on peut être proposées
je voudrais revenir assez rapidement sur
les crédits des volumes politiques
d'insertion par l'activité économique
dont j'ai la conviction que c'est ça a
été démontré au fil du temps à des
outils les plus pertinents pour remettre
des hommes et des femmes en situation
durable de travail il y a dans notre
pays une dynamique sur ce secteur et
donc des parcours d'insertion qui qui
progressent je voudrais cette occasion
saluer les diligences et la réactivité
de toutes les structures d'insertion
pour l'activité économique qui ont été
au rendez-vous ces dernières années pour
moi leur action dans les temps à venir
doit être sensible si nous voulons
effectivement réussir collectivement à
atteindre les 7%
de demandeurs d'emploi qui reste
durablement inscrit à Pôle emploi c'est
ça la cible c'est ça l'objectif
ça va être plus compliqué d'arriver à 5%
et on sait très bien qu'il va falloir
mettre
de l'intelligence de l'innovation des
moyens des parcours des accompagnements
sociaux pro permettre de tester des
solutions pour aller chercher celles et
ceux qui ont des freins à l'emploi qui
soit actuellement les plus éloignés donc
ça impliquera me semble-t-il un souffle
et dans ce budget je m'interroge sur la
réalité d'avoir de donner ce souffle par
le gouvernement dans les moyens il y a
effectivement déjà les postes en
insertion je m'interroge monsieur le
ministre sur la réalité des postes
ouverts contenus de l'inflation en 2023
et je m'interroge je me demande pour
tout dire les choses s'il n'y a pas
mécaniquement une baisse du nombre de
postes ouverts concrètement en 2023 ce
qui serait une très mauvaise chose pour
les demandeurs d'emploi et surtout à
très mauvais signal par rapport au
secteur de l'insertion pour l'activité
économique il y a également et vous
l'avez dit d'ailleurs vous avez fait un
élément dans votre intervention d'un
budget qui progresse sensiblement pour
le hors champ yaho par rapport au budget
socle
certes ça nous permet effectivement
d'innover de tester de d'essayer
d'autres solutions encore faut-il qu'on
y comprenne
qu'on n'y comprenne l'essentiel qu'en
est-il concrètement de ces actions
comment cela va-t-il s'orienter il y a
me semble-t-il un certain nombre
d'interrogations qui peuvent qui peuvent
exister je voudrais également dans la
même veine portée des interrogations par
rapport au crédit sur les sur les
personnes en situation de handicap
je m'interroge pour savoir pourquoi il y
a en réalité une baisse des équivalents
temps plein au titre des crédits ça
m'apparaît là aussi être un mauvais
signal en tout cas c'est inquiétant et
je m'interroge ce faisant je vous pose
la question du pilotage global de ce de
ce système d'une évaluation qui me
paraîtrait de voir être menée pour
savoir où nous en sommes et que chacun
il puisse y comprendre tout ce qui tout
ce que nous devons y comprendre enfin
deux derniers mots sur territoire zéro
chômeur longue durée il y a me
semble-t-il à consensus et une unanimité
à chaque fois que l'assemblée doit se
saisir de ce sujet on sait très bien
qu'on va atteindre le seuil de 50
territoires très prochainement
bah l'idée c'est pas de briser les ailes
de celles et ceux qui veulent aller dans
cette voie là comment envisagez-vous la
suite par rapport à ce qu'avait pu dire
à l'époque celle qui est devenue
désormais première ministre il y a me
semble-t-il un accord de principe mais
ça va parfois mieux le disant et parfois
mieux en légiférant enfin dernière
interrogation sur France compétences
dont la manifestement j'ai pour tout
dire autant j'ai beaucoup de beaucoup
d'interrogations et même d'inquiétude
des crédits budgétaires qui ne cessent
d'être
voté enfin qu'ils sont invités à les
voter pour équilibrer cette entité dont
on peut effectivement être inquiet de de
son fonctionnement de sa pertinence
on est obligé de mettre beaucoup au pot
pour un résultat qui peut encore être
discuté avec ce faisant également des
créations de poste en 2023 donc voilà
sur France compétences des doutes sur ce
qui a pu être mis en place et une
volonté qu'on beaucoup plus clair voilà
les quelques interrogations que je
pouvais faire sur les crédits tels qui
nous ont été présentés merci Monsieur
Viry monsieur Adrien Clouet pour la
France insoumise du Pesse merci
beaucoup collègue ministre je remarque
le tour de parole a été un peu inversé
j'espère que ce n'est pas l'atmosphère
49-3 qui conduit déjà à
repousser certaines prises de parole
ça m'évitera de d'être taquin sur le
sujet ultérieurement alors merci
beaucoup pour l'occasion d'avoir la
discussion sur cette mission qui me
paraît requérir de poser plusieurs
questions et de poser un débat important
la première c'est celle de la nature
politique du problème que nous sommes
amenés à discuter s'agit-il de traiter
la question du chômage ou s'agit-il de
traiter la question de la privation
d'emploi posez cette question ça
implique un choix très fort à la fois
économique et morale puisque le chômage
on le dans notre pays cela concerne les
personnes qui recherchent une manière
jugée appropriée un emploi qui sont
disponibles dans l'immédiat qui n'ont
pas exercer une seule heure d'activité
ça c'est la question du chômage mais à
cette question s'ajoute et même je pense
ce superpose de manière plus importante
la question de la privation d'emploi
c'est-à-dire les personnes qui sont
tenues éloignées de l'emploi quel que
soit leur condition d'existence ou leur
comportement et si on pose la question
dans ces termes on est plus en train de
d'interroger le destin de 2 millions de
personnes qui seraient au chômage on est
en train d'interroger le destin de 8
millions de nos compatriotes qui sont
tenus éloignés de l'emploi pour elle et
pour eux le 49-3 patronal c'est tous les
jours sur le marché du travail d'autant
plus que les hausses d'emploi qui ont pu
être évoquées durant les interventions
précédentes ou dans les textes présentés
sont largement artificiels 150 000
emplois liés à des micros entreprises
300000 liés à des contrats
d'apprentissage qui valent aujourd'hui
des primes ou des subventions tout à
fait exorbitantes qui reviennent parfois
à avoir une années de travail en
entreprise qui est complètement rémunéré
par le contribuable c'est-à-dire que
vous avez des personnes qui travaillent
et qui payent les impôts servant
intégralement voire même plus à payer
leurs propres salaires et leurs propres
employeur tout ça s'inscrit dans un
moment une dynamique où on assiste à une
floraison de travail à caractère gratuit
ou quasi gratuit lorsqu'il s'agit
d'emploi ou d'activités qui sont
rémunérés sous le niveau du SMIC je
pense évidemment aux apprentis aux
alternants de moins de 16 ans ou
stagiaires au service civique aux
assistantes maternelles au travail
carcéral ou aux employés en ESAT bref
nous avons aujourd'hui des millions de
personnes dans ce pays qui exercent une
activité interchangeable avec d'autres
qui sont occupés sur un poste de travail
qui est commun à d'autres personnes mais
qui sont rémunérés en dessous de ce qui
est jugé être le minimum légal de
dignité impliquant donc qu'il y a
différentes formes de dignité sur le
marché du travail dans notre pays et
même le salariat de droit commun même le
garagiste même la pâtissière connaisse
depuis le début de l'année une
diminution de des revenus de leur
travail moins 3% de salaire réel cette
année ça représente pour quelqu'un qui
est payé 2000 euros par mois une perte
de 60 euros mensuel c'est-à-dire que la
personne qui travaille la même manière
du mois de janvier au mois de décembre
démarre l'année à 2000 euros fini
l'année à 1940 au moment des fêtes de
Noël ce qui me semble constitué un
cadeau quelque peu discutable voir
douteux la set crise des salaires elle
n'existe pas partout évidemment elle
s'arrête dans le salariat jusqu'à
2503000 euros puisque au niveau des très
grandes entreprises notamment au niveau
du CAC 40 nous avons des informations
récentes extrêmement intéressantes je
change ici au rapport que nous a remis
l'IRES la semaine dernière indiquant que
160 milliards d'euros par an d’être
public était versé au plus grandes
entreprises du pays 160 milliards
d'euros qui correspondent à un quart des
salaires du secteur privé ce qui
autrement dit signifie que tous les gens
qui nous écoutent rendent à peu près 1 €
sur 4 alors employeur pour travailler
donc il y a aujourd'hui dans ce pays des
problèmes majeurs en termes d'usage de
l'argent public et des problèmes majeurs
en termes de sous rémunération du
travail lesquels qui constitue qu'un
seul et même problème dès lors à quoi
sert ce budget travail et emploi il y a
des hausses qui ont été mentionnées par
le ministre lesquels sont presque
exclusivement liés à l'apparition des
milliards supplémentaires pour
l'apprentissage et à côté des coupes qui
m'apparaissent relativement sauvage dans
tout ce qui est socialement utile je
pense au programme 102 les moins 5% de
dotation concernant les allocations
chômage versées par l'État qui ne
correspondent pas à exclusivement
contrairement à ce qui a été dit un
retour à l'emploi mais bien une baisse
des moyens alloués au contrat aidé de
même sur les contrats engagement jeunes
on y lit la cible de 400 000 jeunes
c'est ce qui pourrait sembler
effectivement très enthousiasmant a
priori sauf que cela regroupe les 200
000 de la garantie jeune en mission
locale et les 240 000 l'accompagnement
intensif apôle emploi donc c'est la
représente une perte sèche de 40 000
bref on assiste bel et bien à une mise
en cause de la notion de droit qui a été
ouverte avec la réforme de l'assurance
chômage et ça me permet en conclusion
de revenir sur la réponse que m'ont
apporté vos services aujourd'hui je les
en remercie à une question écrite
concernant les allongements
exceptionnels de la période
d'affiliation pour les chômeuses et les
chômeurs vous avez répondu vos services
ont répondu les allocataires qui
s'estimentés sont invités à saisir le
médiateur de Pôle Emploi dois-je donc
comprendre que vous faites des lois dans
les conséquences doivent être contestés
avec votre approbation devant une
médiation
merci merci d'avoir essayé de tenir le
temps Monsieur Nicolas turquois pour les
démocrates modernes et indépendants
merci madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre monsieur le rapporteur chers
collègues l'analyse des crédits la
mission travail emploie revue une
importance toute particulière chaque
année puisque celle-ci donne la tendance
de la politique publique de soutien à
l'emploi dans notre pays cette année
elle s'effectue dans un contexte
globalement positif en effet notre pays
connaît un recul du chômage continue ces
dernières années le taux de chômage
devrait selon les prévisions de l'Insee
c'est-à-dire à 7,4% à la fin de l'année
restant stable par rapport à 2021 malgré
le naître ralentissement de l'activité
économique pour les raisons que nous
connaissons tous
cela nous satisfait mais nous engage
surtout à poursuivre le travail engagé
depuis 2017 pour parvenir en pleine
emploi car nous restons convaincus que
le travail est un levier d'insertion
déterminant et primordial dans notre
société
nous nous réjouissons que pour l'année
2023 les crédits de cette mission soit
en aide augmentation de près de 4,5
milliards soit 28,47 % d'augmentation en
autorisation d'engagement et de 6,2
milliards d'euros en crédit de paiement
soit 42,57%
cette tendance haussière est
indispensable pour mener bien le
déploiement des référents entreprises
qui vise à réduire les inégalités
d'accès à l'emploi et à développer les
compétences professionnelles de
l'ensemble de nos concitoyens
le programme 102 relatif à l'accès au
retour à l'emploi connaît une légère
baisse de l'ordre de 5 % en réseau
notamment des prévisions de diminution
du nombre de bénéficiaires des
allocations de solidarité pour les
personnes en fin de droit l'assurance
chômage
cela est cohérent avec la trajectoire de
baisse du nombre de demandeurs d'emploi
dans le même programme tenant à saluer
la hausse des crédits au secteur de
l'insertion par l'activité économique
par l'intermédiaire du Fonds d'inclusion
dans l'emploi il s'agit d'un secteur
dans lequel notre groupe c'est beaucoup
investi lors de la dernière légitime
pure par l'intermédiaire de notre
ancienne collègue Michel de Vaucouleurs
il faut saluer si le travail mené par
les acteurs que sont les associations
intermédiaires les entreprises et les
ateliers d'insertion ils
œuvrent au quotidien pour que chacun
puisse s'insérer dans notre société ici
épanouissent
le programme 102 voit également la
traduction budgétaire du contrat
d'engagement jeune instauré dans la
dernière loi de finance les quelques 800
millions d'euros prévus devront
permettre aux missions locales et à Pôle
Emploi d'accompagner 300 000 jeunes pour
l'année 2023 de 200000 nouveaux
bénéficiaires ce dispositif
hérité du plan de relance doit continuer
sa montée en charge afin de permettre
l'entrée pérenne sur le marché du
travail des jeunes les plus en
difficulté
ce programme contient également les
crédits destinés à l'expérimentation
territoire zéro chômeur de langue durée
récemment prolongée élargi ce dispositif
monte ainsi en charge puisque ces
crédits doubles par rapport à 2021
pouvez-vous monsieur le ministre nous
faire un point d'étape sur les
procédures de l'agrément dans les
territoires et l'évaluation du rapport
bénéfice coût de ce dispositif
en outre l'augmentation substantielle
des crédits du programme 103 est
satisfaisant dans la mesure où cela va
permettre de poursuivre la dynamique
observée ces dernières années notamment
dans le déploiement du plan
d'investissement dans les compétences
si nous avons conscience que cette eau
c'est largement dû au transfert des
crédits liés à l'activité partielle qui
figurait auparavant dans la mission plan
de relance nous souhaiterions interroger
monsieur le ministre sur plusieurs
aspects de ce programme
d'abord sur l'apprentissage la dynamique
créée par l'emploi pour la liberté de
choisir son avenir professionnel a été
réel et nous devons être fier toutefois
les nombreuses aides mises en oeuvre
dans le cadre de ce crise sanitaire
n'ont pas vocation être pérennisé ainsi
Monsieur le Ministre pouvez-vous nous
indiquer comment comptez-vous maintenir
ces dynamiques en revenant à un
financement plus classique des contrats
d'apprentissage quel dispositif de
soutien pourrait être reconduit
ensuite sur la formation professionnelle
nous sommes tous au fait des difficultés
de l'opérateur France compétence qui est
bénéficié de transfert de trésorerie
exceptionnel en loi de finance
rectificative pouvez-vous nous indiquer
la situation actuelle de celui-ci
quelles ajustements sont envisagées pour
le faire parvenir à l'équilibre
budgétaire par ailleurs la question de
la gouvernance de France compétence est
toujours épineuse qu'en est-il enfin
nous avons posé très récemment les
jalons d'une réforme de la VAE dans la
loi portant en mesure d'urgence relative
au fonctionnement du marché du travail
en vue du plein emploi la traduction
budgétaire de celle-ci ne semble pas
encore être prévue dans la mission
puisque l'enveloppe reste constante
ainsi Monsieur le Ministre pouvez-vous
nous indiquer quels moyens
supplémentaire seront fournis pour
réussir cette réforme ambitieuse et
attendue en conclusion le groupe
démocrate salut un budget en
augmentation et adapté aux besoins du
marché du travail et votre a donc les
crédits la mission
merci Monsieur turproi monsieur
Delaporte Arthur pour le groupe
socialiste et apparenté nuesse
notre collègue Pierre d'arrivier nous
invitait à profiter du moment présent
Carpe Diem quoi minimum crédula postéro
cueille le jour présent sans te soucier
du lendemain nous disait Horace
faudrait-il ajouter sans te soucier des
minutes qui arrivent puisque la première
ministre est en train à l'instant que je
vous parle de pénétrer dans l'enceinte
de cet assemblée pour nous imposer le
couper du 49-3 qui mettra fin à la
discussion budgétaire du moins en partie
donc faut-il que je m'interrompre dès
maintenant ou que j'essaie au moins
quelques secondes de tenter une
discussion sur la mission qui qui nous
occupe alors il semblerait que la
première ministre reste dans sa voiture
pour l'instant je peux donc continuer
mon propos
une minute une minute mais il me reste 4
ce ne sera pas forcément suffisant mais
je vous ai bien écouté monsieur le
ministre j'ai lu les documents
budgétaires qui vendent
j'étais de nouveau coupé
j'ai lu les documents budgétaires qui se
vendent d'une augmentation de 28% des
crédits en autorisation d'engagement et
42% en crédit de paiement soit environ 6
milliards d'euros
[Musique]
6,23 or l'essentiel c'est évidemment
l'augmentation du coût de
l'apprentissage et derrière des baisses
aussi substantielles on évoquait tout à
l'heure
le
programme 102 j'y reviendrai bref ce
budget qui finance la politique de
l'emploi et de la formation et
révélateur finalement des choix
idéologiques politiques qui sont les
vôtres et qui se concrétisent par des
régressions notamment en droit du
travail
donc je la première ministre est en
sortie de sa voiture continuer mais je
demanderai de la porte on est là on
travaille mais en même temps il se passe
quelque chose d'important dans notre
dans notre Parlement dans notre
hémicycle et je pense que notre place
sera là où est la première ministre au
moment où elle parlera et je au moment
où je me rappelle suspension de séance
merci
l'aide exceptionnelle à l'apprentissage
à profiter au plus diplômé c'est cela
que je voulais dire 51% des apprentis
prépare un diplôme de niveau BTS ou
supérieur contre 38% en 2018 pourquoi
finançons-nous des formations au sein
d'entreprises de communication par
exemple éloigné de l'idée même de la
logique de l'apprentissage qui voulait
être plus en faveur de ceux qui en
avaient vraiment besoin c'est votre
enveloppe l'augmentation que que vous
faites pour l'apprentissage ne serait
compensé par ailleurs les baisses du
budget depuis 2017 et la baisse ciblée
de certaines actions et notamment la
location de solidarité des demandeurs
d'emploi avec une baisse de 21% les
contrats aidés 7% ou encore la ridicule
augmentation des critiques fléchés vers
Pôle emploi de 0,9% qui ne couvre ni
l'inflation ni la réforme de l'assurance
chômage qui est on l'a dit ces dernières
semaines une dizaine à gaz qui
pénalisera des agents de Pôle Emploi qui
sont déjà surmenés enfin Monsieur le
Ministre au-delà de l'apprentissage donc
vos bulser de 500 millions d'euros
l'action concernant les demandeurs
d'emploi en poursuivant votre politique
d'austérité pour les plus précaires
alors même qu'il reste 5 millions de
chômeurs dans notre pays cette baisse
est inexplicable ou alors elle est la
conséquence de vos réformes qui je le
rappelle devait être pour le plein
emploi mais que constater aujourd'hui
c'est bien la nécessité pour les
demandeurs d'emploi d'avoir un
accompagnement pour leur réinsertion
pour autant quand on regarde le
portefeuille des nombres des demandeurs
d'emploi accompagnés par conseiller on
est à 53,6 demandeurs d'emploi par
conseillers contre 46 en 2017 pour un
accompagnement global et 4406 demandeurs
d'emploi contre 336 en
pour un accompagnement suivi ça c'est la
réalité de Pôle Emploi aujourd'hui en
dépit de votre discours rhétorique sur
la question du Pôle emploi je
j'accompagnerai mes remarques dans les
42 secondes qui me reste des de
l'évocation et des inquiétudes de mon
collègue Dave ville sur France travail
sur l'inspection du travail notamment le
rapporteur alerté sur la qualité de
l'emploi et notamment sur le plafond en
équivalent temple un établissement comme
pôle emploi doit être exemplaire pour
permettre à ces agents d'accompagner au
mieux les privés d'emplois or selon les
syndicats monsieur d'arrivée de
souligner la proportion de personnel en
CDT et passer de 5% en 2019 à 13% en
2021 avec des disparités locales très
fortes ce n'est pas acceptable en tout
cas monsieur le ministre j'espère que
vous ne l'acceptez pas cette
précarisation croissante du service
public de l'emploi et je m'arrêterai ici
alors que nous aurions évidemment
beaucoup d'autres sujets à aborder comme
le handicap merci Monsieur Delaporte je
donne la parole à Monsieur François
Gernigon pour le groupe horizon et oui
merci madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre je vais être bref et
synthétique la mission travaillait
emploi du projet de loi pour 2023
traduit donc les ambitions du
gouvernement en matière d'emploi de
formation professionnelle et de santé au
travail pour 2023 elle traduit les
ambitions du gouvernement
alors que nous examinons pour la
première fois au cours de la législature
les crédits de la mission travaillant
je souhaite appeler que ces crédits vise
à poursuivre et améliorer les
dispositifs déployés depuis 2017 et qui
ont porté leurs fruits à la fois avec un
taux de chômage au plus bas depuis 2008
avec la réforme de l'apprentissage la
jeunesse est mieux armée dans ses
premiers pas dans le monde du travail à
la fois au niveau de la formation et
dans l'accès à l'emploi et avec le
quatrième plan santé au travail qui vise
à prévenir les risques et accompagner
les entreprises et leurs salariés
au nom du groupe horizon je salue votre
travail monsieur le ministre pour
l'effort réalisé afin d'augmenter les
crédits alloués qui atteignent près de
21 milliards d'euros soit une
augmentation de 43%. cet effort montre
votre volonté de pérenniser et améliorer
des mesures ambitieuses
nous nous interrogeons sur l'application
concrète du programme dédié à la
mutation de l'économie comment l'État
au-delà de des moyens financiers
souhaitent-ils accompagner les
entreprises notamment vers la transition
écologique et numérique
nous saluons la volonté de ne laisser
personne de côté permettant ainsi à ceux
d'entre eux qui sont le plus éloignés du
travail de retrouver un emploi et
construire véritablement une société
plus inclusive
il est en effet impératif de maintenir
des efforts ciblés pour le retour à
l'activité des personnes les plus
fragilisées sur le marché du travail
ainsi qu'en direction des territoires
les plus en difficulté en travaillant à
la transformation du service public de
l'emploi
enfin nous nous interrogeons quant au
déploiement d'actions d'accompagnement
des métiers en tension en effet dans mon
territoire des métiers souffrent d'un
certain manque d'attractivité alors que
les offres d'emploi sont nombreuses je
pense notamment aux métiers de
l'accompagnement à la personne nous en
avons déjà parlé notamment avec madame
la ministre
vos ministères prennent leur part dans
des travaux à venir je pense évidemment
au CNR bien vieillir qui devrait
permettre d'apporter des solutions dans
le cas concret des métiers de
l'accompagnement
cependant d'ici là quel plan le
gouvernement envisage-t-il d'établir
pour rendre ses professions plus
attractives ce qui veulent peuvent
sortir de la commission
des mesures sont-elles prévues
en ce sens dans les travaux que vous
menez en amont dans la réforme de la
formation professionnelle pour la
création de France travail je vous
remercie
vous avez terminé excusez-moi j'étais un
peu
merci je donne la parole à Madame
Sandrine Rousseau du groupe écologiste
nupes merci Madame
allez-y
donc merci madame la Présidente et
vraiment cet exercice est très étonnant
de devoir parler sur quelque chose qui
va être éliminé dans les dans les
minutes qui viennent bref alors donc sur
la mission travailler emploi de la
deuxième partie du PLF le groupe
écologie c'est d'abord réjoui de voir la
tendance générale à l'augmentation des
crédits alloués sur cette mission
toutefois en regardant avec précision ce
budget reconnaissons que pour
l'essentiel ces augmentations résulte 1
de la nécessité de financement des
objectifs de la mission dans un contexte
inflationniste fort de surtout de la
compensation de la disparition du
programme de la mission plan de relance
dont les crédits de paiement s'élever en
2022 à 3,7 milliards d'euros derrière
les aspects budgétaires nous regrettons
les baisses importantes portées sur le
programme d'accès et de retour à
l'emploi qui perd plus de 377 millions
d'euros par rapport à 2022 nous ne
comprenons pas le sens de la baisse
irresponsable des financements à
destination des allocations de
solidarité pour les personnes en fin de
droit à l'assurance chômage alors même
que les deux dernières la forme de
l'assurance chômage auront pour effet
des fins de droit plus précoces de même
le budget alloué à ce programme ne
permet pas d'enrayer la baisse du
plafond d'emploi pardon de Pôle emploi
et cela alors même que les conditions de
travail sont largement dégradées que les
CDDs se multiplient faisant ainsi portés
par les personnels précaires la
politique d'emploi d'autres personnes
encore plus précaires nous regrettons
également l'absence cette année de
fléchage de crédit sur la lutte contre
le travail illégal assuré par une
inspection du travail en crise faute
d'effectif et de moyens suffisants de
manière plus générale ce budget marque
la poursuite d'un investissement massif
pour des exonérations sans aucune
condition sociale et environnementale
forte des dispositifs sous-dimensionnés
qui font pourtant leurs preuves sur le
terrain
pardon
aucune ambition par ailleurs sur la
transformation et l'accompagnement de
secteurs appelés à se transformer en
raison de la crise climatique et enfin
un abandon des jeunes qui sont de plus
en plus en difficulté un exemple la
baisse du financement des contrats aidés
qui concerneront qui concerneuront 110
000 personnes contre 145 000 en 2022 et
450 000 en 2016 et cela au détriment des
jeunes qui pourraient ainsi entrer dans
l'emploi au prix d'une nouvelle
fragilisation du tissu associatif qui
bénéficie de marge de manœuvre
budgétaires de plus en plus limité en
raison notamment de la crise financière
de certaines collectivités territoriales
ou encore l'accompagnement des jeunes en
difficulté qui pourra concerner au
maximum 300 000 bénéficiaires trop
faibles en regard des 1 million 500 000
jeunes âgés de 15 à 29 ans qui ne sont
ni en emploi ni en étude ni en formation
dans un contexte où les réformes chômage
ou RSA à venir précariseront plutôt que
améliorer le niveau de l'emploi en
France les écologistes appellent le
gouvernement à mettre en place les
propositions maintes fois répétées dans
nos débats en séance l'abaissement du
revenu du temps de travail la formation
la transformation écologique de notre
économie l'investissement dans les
services publics qui souffrent
aujourd'hui de difficultés d'embauche
faute d'attractivité nous proposerons
par voie d'amendements plusieurs
plusieurs pistes comme la création d'une
d'un véritable service public de
l'enfance le soutien à la formation
professionnelle le renforcement des
financements à destination des
territoires zéro chômeurs bref une
ambition pour la question du travail
oui excusez-moi monsieur Yannick Money
pour le groupe gauche-démocrate et
républicaine nupes merci merci madame la
présidente monsieur le ministre monsieur
le rapporteur juste une remarque avant
de poser trois questions précises au
ministre je suis très surpris de la
grande satisfaction mon font preuve les
élus de la majorité sur les questions
d'emploi
parce que quand on sort des murs de
l'Assemblée nationale on a un tout autre
discours de la part des populations que
l'on rencontre de nos permanence et
j'imagine que vous aussi c'est le cas et
je pense que l'autosatisfaction appuyait
dont vous faites preuve cache en fait
une vraie fébrilité face aux sans emploi
que vous arrivez certes à cacher dans
les chiffres mais qui ne se cache pas
dans la vraie vie le ministre l'article
deuxième chose deuxième remarque
les 5% c'est un objectif c'est un leurre
c'est pas compliqué d'arriver à 5% il
suffit de restreindre des inscriptions
et de du coup de décourager les gens
comme vous l'avez fait que la réforme
d'assurance chômage décourager les gens
à s'inscrire effectivement on arrivera
très vite à 5%. l'article 47 du projet
de loi de finances proroge d'une année
deux expérimentations créées par la loi
du sein de septembre 2018 pour la
liberté de choisir son avenir
professionnel le dispositif baptisé
c'est d'aider emplois et le dispositif
de l'entreprise adaptée de travail
temporaire qui vise à favoriser
l'émergence de structures de travail
temporaire tourné vers les travailleurs
handicapés le gouvernement demande la
prorogation de ces deux dispositifs au
motifs de la crise sanitaire et
économique a eu pour effet de
neutraliser une année d'expérimentation
en raison de la baisse de l'activité
économique du rapport d'évaluation de la
loi avenir professionnel il ressortait
qu'il est encore tôt pour faire le bilan
de ses dispositifs en raison du manque
de recul dans le temps la DG EFP a
toutefois indiqué aux rapporteur que le
nombre de CDD tremplins conclu n'était
pas à la hauteur des ambitions initiales
alors j'ai trois questions le nombre de
structures habilités à mettre en oeuvre
ses dispositives et le nombre de
bénéficiaires correspondent-ils à
présent aux attentes du gouvernement les
résultats produits par les deux
dispositifs ont-ils fait l'objet d'une
évaluation
dispose-t-on déjà d'informations sur le
parcours professionnel des bénéficiaires
une fois sortis de ces dispositifs et je
m'excuse par avance mais je ne pourrais
pas écouter votre réponse puisque je
pense qu'il y a quelque chose qui se
passe dans l'hémicycle je vous remercie
mais vous êtes tout à fait excusez
monsieur je vais donner maintenant la
parole au rapporteur spécial de la
commission des finances pour deux
minutes Monsieur Dominique Da Silva
merci
merci madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Ministre avec une progression de près de
30% des autorisations d'engagement et de
plus de 40% des crédits de paiement le
cap de la mission est affirmé il s'agit
bien donc de viser le plein emploi il
serait trop long de faire ici
l'inventaire exhaustif des outils
mobilisés au service de cet objectif
mais il est bon quand même de rappeler
et de souligner particulièrement la
poursuite des efforts exceptionnels
engagés en faveur des compétences et ce
depuis la loi du 5 septembre 2018 pour
la liberté de choisir son avenir
professionnel en cohérence avec le
programme présidentiel et l'objectif
d'un million d'apprentis par an d'ici à
2027 le gouvernement continue une action
volontariste en accompagnant la
dynamique de l'apprentissage avec une
trésorerie de France compétences soutenu
à hauteur de 1,7 milliards d'euros de
nombreux programmes et actions lancés
dans le cadre du plan d'investissement
dans les compétences poursuivent
également doté de milliards d'euros pour
l'année 2023 avec par exemple FNE
formation dédié à la formation des
demandeurs d'emploi un dispositif pas
très connu mais qui bénéficie cependant
de 300 millions d'euros supplémentaires
en autorisation d'engagement et de 95
millions supplémentaires en crédit de
paiement dès cette année en 203 aussi
Monsieur le Ministre pouvez-vous nous en
dire plus sur cet outil particulier et
les résultats obtenus je vous remercie
merci Monsieur Da Silva monsieur le
ministre merci madame la Présidente
Mesdames et Messieurs députés messieurs
les rapporteur je vais bref à mon tour
et on aimerait conscience que le moment
est particulier même si le gouvernement
engagé sa responsabilité sur la première
partie du projet de loi de finance et
que cela ne perd pas comme contrairement
à ce que j'ai pu entendre la discussion
sur la seconde je voudrais simplement
apporter quelques éléments de réponse à
monsieur le rapporteur pour dire mais ça
fait quoi plusieurs interventions y
compris de celles et ceux qui nous ont
quittés j'assume totalement la
différence de Périm nous sommes avec un
budget qui dépasse les 20 milliards
d'euros avec un effet de périmètre que
j'ai dit au tout début de mon propos
liminaire sur des dispositifs du plan de
relance autour du fneux autour des
primes d'apprentissage qui est financé
sur le plan de relance et que nos
réintégrons je pense que nous pouvons
nous féliciter pour ceux qui sont
attachés à ces dispositifs que ce soit
intégrés alors que la logique du plan de
relance était plutôt de se terminer à la
fin de l'année 2022 je pense que nous
finançons effectivement des dynamiques
autour de la compensation des
exonérations nous n'ajoutons pas
d'exonération vous l'avez noté sur le
rapporteur c'est une dynamique
d'exonération de compensation
d'exonération qui est liée à la
dynamique de l'emploi ce qui est la
traduction d'une bonne nouvelle sur le
front de l'emploi et il est logique
normal que l'État en tout cas par le
budget de l'État nous finançons la
compensation auprès des organismes de
sécurité sociale il y a un point qui me
m'a surpris mais pas dans votre
intervention parce que vous l'avez dit
sous forme d'interrogations puisque sous
forme de dénonciation c'est qu'on puisse
interroger sur l'évolution du P02 le
p102 présente des dispositions à la
hausse de l'insertion par l'activité
économique je vais y revenir les
différents dispositifs et globalement
une légère réflexion à la baisse du fait
de la diminution du des crédits
consacrés aux allocations spécifiques de
solidarité aux allocution de solidarité
mais la SS fait 95% de ce cette action
là c'est la traduction véritablement
mathématique du fait que 146 000
demandeurs d'emploi de très longue durée
et retrouver de l'activité et donc c'est
la traduction d'une bonne nouvelle
souhaitez l'augmentation de ce début de
budget j'ai cru le comprendre dans
certaines interventions ça signifie
mécaniquement souhaiter l'augmentation
du nombre de bénéficiaires de la SS je
pense que personne ne souhaite qu'on
augmente le nombre de bénéficiaires de
la SS et qu'on se félicite plutôt quand
des bénéficiaires de la SS retrouvent le
chemin de l'emploi et sortent un site du
dispositif donc c'est vraiment cette
traduction là que nous avons fait au
travers du p102 sur les activités de
conseil vous dire que le ministère du
travail n'aura recours à aucun cabinet
de conseil serait mentir j'applique
strictement la circulaire qui encadre le
recours guide des conseils nous créons
des postes au sein d'un des jeux FP en
particulier pour internaliser des qui
jusqu'à présent les actions qui étaient
jusqu'à présent externalisées à des
cabinets de conseils et pour l'essentiel
les conseils restants restent en
particulier des conseils en matière
d'informatique de système d'information
dont nous ne pourrons pas nécessairement
nous passer donc faire preuve de mesure
dans le recours au cabinet de conseils
respecter la circulaire respecter les
objectifs de baisse en pourcentage du
recours tel que le gouvernement s'y est
engagé et c'est ce à quoi nous nous
employons par ces moyens humains que
nous intégrons de la même manière vous
m'avez interrogé sur la question de la
communication
cela représente malgré finalement 10
milliards 10 millions sur 20 milliards
donc ça reste quand même assez mesuré
dans le poids des dépenses du ministère
et nous voulons accompagner des
campagnes de communication autour de la
mise en place de France travail et
autour de la mise en place d'un certain
nombre de réformes qui nécessite des
explications et qui nécessite aussi
d'avoir recours à cette communication
j'en viens sur les questions relatives à
l'insertion par l'activité économique en
souhaitant vous rassurer les crédits que
nous prévoyons sont des crédits en
augmentation et j'invite à la fois la
comparaison par rapport à la loi de
finance initiale 2022 mais plus encore
par rapport à la réalisation de 2022
parce que la réalité que sur les trois
dernières années et le covid n'est pas
pour rien les objectifs n'ont pas été
atteints en termes de nombre de places
et donc de nombre de personnes
concernées et donc nous sommes sur une
augmentation qui correspond à 7000
places de plus par rapport au réaliser
2022 et en tenant compte de l'inflation
et donc il y aura plus de place financer
en matière d'insertion là où nous avons
encore des discussions et au-delà de la
maquette qui vous est présentée c'est
sur la répartition entre les différentes
structures pour les entreprises adaptées
nous sommes sur une stabilité du nombre
de places avec des crédits augmentent
pour accompagner un certain dévolution
et tenir compte là aussi des effets
d'inflation
sur la question relative à France
travail la forme juridique n'est pas
arrêtée mais j'ai eu l'occasion de le
dire le 13 septembre c'est avant tout de
la coordination c'est la volonté d'un
diagnostic et d'une orientation partagée
en aucun cas la fusion des acteurs de
l'emploi que nous connaissons
aujourd'hui ça n'est pas la fusion de
Pôle emploi des missions locales comme
j'ai parfois pu l'entendre ça n'est pas
non plus la fusion d'organismes entre
eux soit parce qu'il le souhaite ou ce
qui le demande mais en tout cas ça n'est
pas l'orientation que nous avons que
nous avons retenu sur les questions
relatives à territoire zéro chômeurs de
longue durée
nous avons une trajectoire qui permet de
tenir les engagements qui sont pris et
entre le budget 2022 pardon et le budget
20223 nous passons de 36 à 45 millions
d'euros nous sommes dans cette enveloppe
si je puis dire de 60 territoires
autorisés 10 depuis l'expérimentation
2016 52 plus depuis 2020 et il y a un
certain nombre de discussions
aujourd'hui qui porte à la fois sur ce
que nous devons faire lorsque nous
atteindrons les 60 nous avons la
possibilité de déroger par un décret de
conseil d'État mais il y a aussi des
questions qui portent sur l'évaluation
et nous devons mettre en place cette
évaluation telle que c'est prévu par la
loi qui fixe l'expérimentation pour en
tirer le meilleur parti et ainsi
confronter l'ensemble des points de vue
au sujet de cette évaluation
sur les questions relatives au contrat
engagements jeunes nous sommes sur 300
000 et ça marquera un progrès puisque
les 300 000 de l'année 2022 sont 300.000
qui intègre aussi les garanties jeunes
qui ont été qui ont été réalisés sur
France compétences nous avons
effectivement une difficulté l'État
intervient directement en loi de
financier initiale à hauteur de 2
milliards d'euros c'est la première fois
habituellement nous avons traité cela
uniquement en PLFR et donc nous aurons
l'occasion certainement au cours de
l'année de revoir en fonction du niveau
des primes d'apprentissage en fonction
de l'évolution du niveau de prise en
charge des coûts ce que nous pouvons
faire et j'ajoute à cela le travail que
nous faisons autour du compte personnel
de formation je termine sans avoir été
exhaustif sur deux aspects en
particulier qui ont été évoqués par
beaucoup d'entre vous je pense à Pôle
emploi et pardonnez-moi Pôle emploi et à
l'inspection du travail avant d'en venir
à ces deux points je vais simplement
dire que en matière de mutation
économique d'accompagnement des
transitions les outils dont nous
disposons sont pourquoi les crédits de
France 2030 je pense tout
particulièrement à l'appel à
manifestation d'intérêt sur les
compétences et les métiers d'avenir qui
nous permettra d'apporter des crédits
extra budgétaires et donc des réponses à
ces questions là je pense aussi à ce que
nous faisons en matière de transition
collective et de effet de formation
puisque là aussi l'objectif est
clairement de former à la fois du
reclassement pour des salariés
d'entreprises en difficulté mais aussi
de la montée en compétences ou de
l'évolution de compétences pour des
salariés d'entreprises dans des process
technologiques évoluent j'étais hier
comme certains d'entre vous peut-être
avec les professionnels de l'automobile
et le groupe Renault par exemple évalue
presque 20 000 personnes parmi ces
salariés ceux qui doivent être formés à
de nouvelles technologies à de
l'hybrides de l'hydrogène alors qu'ils
ont été formés à des moteurs thermiques
les deux points par lesquels je veux
terminer concerne donc Pôle emploi et
la situation l'inspection du travail
pour vous dire que pour ce qui concerne
Pôle Emploi entre les crédits exécutés
2017 et 2018 qui s'élevait hors pacte
régionaux d'investissement dans les
compétences à 5 millions de
165,260 milliards en moyenne sur 2007 et
2018 nous serons en 2023 à 6,480
milliards donc c'est une augmentation
qui est nette d'un milliard deux un peu
plus d'un milliardeux or crédit consacré
au plan d'investissement dans les
compétences pour leur voler régional
pour ce qui concerne les moyens humains
dont dispose dont dispose Pôle Emploi
nous passons pour les emplois permanents
de 40 46 742 en 2017 à 48 847 en 2022
soit une augmentation de 2100 et bien
s'ajouter à cela des emplois en CDD ou
en contrat d'apprentissage qui s'élevait
à 3176 en 2017 et qui s'élève à 3990 en
2022 lorsqu'on additionne le tout nous
passons de 49 918 à 52 837 et qui va
l'entente plein pour Pôle emploi et je
précise que nous sommes en 2023 comme en
2022 sur environ 4%
un peu moins de 4%
pardonnez-moi un peu moins de 5% de CDD
dans la masse globale des emplois de des
emplois de Pôle Emploi donc nous
veillons à cela et nous avons fait en
sorte que les emplois créés notamment à
l'occasion de la crise soit dans leur
immense majorité maintenu de manière à
accompagner à la fois la mise en œuvre
du plan de réduction des tensions et
l'amélioration de l'accompagnement et
son intensification enfin pour ce qui
concerne l'inspection du travail
dirham sur la porteur que vous avez
raison sur un certain nombre de points
et sur les difficultés qui sont
rencontrées ça n'est malheureusement pas
15% de vacances que nous constatons ce
même 16 et cela renvoie des difficultés
qui sont des difficultés structurelles
et importantes difficultés liées à
l'attractivité des métiers nous essayons
d'y répondre il y a eu un centre de
revalorisation de grises j'ai inscrit
effectivement 2,5 millions d'euros qui
viennent s'ajouter à des crédits en
gestion sur 2022 pour revaloriser ce de
l'inspection du travail nous maintenons
le dispositif de nomination d'inspecteur
par détachement pour permettre aussi
d'avoir de nouveaux canaux de
recrutement nous maintenons les
possibilités hors fonction d'inspection
bien sûr de recrutement de contractuels
pour apporter un apport administratif au
service de l'inspection du travail et
nous avons augmenté de manière très
sensible les promotions puisque nous
avons créé 200 postes ouvrir de son
poste d'inspecteur du travail en plus
dans les différents concours et les
différents modes de recrutement nous
devons aussi travailler sur la
clarification de l'organisation il est
en réalité deux mouvements qui se sont
rencontrés le premier mouvement qui
concerne l'inspection forte de 2015 avec
notamment la création le confortement
des responsables d'unités qui pénètre
leur place il faut dire les choses comme
elles comme elles sont et en même temps
que l'organisation territoriale de
l'État avec des secrétariats généraux
communs qui eux sont sur une logique
très horizontale il faut qu'on veille à
la fois la ligne hiérarchique du SIT qui
est particulière régie par la convention
de l'OIT et à ce fonctionnement
horizontal et donc il y a un certain
nombre d'irritants diront très technique
sur des EPI sur des voitures de fonction
etc irritant d'ailleurs qui rendent
difficile le fait de répondre à votre
sur les moyens puisque les moyens les
moyens supports ne sont pas dans le
programme de l'inspection mais sur des
programmes des secrétariats généraux
interministériels donc nous devons
répondre à cela et ça fait partie des
discussions que j'aurai notamment demain
en comité technique ministériel y
compris sur la répartition de
l'enveloppe liée à l'ifse nous avons
effectivement un rapport d'igase sur le
rôle des responsables d'unités de
contrôle et sera très prochainement
organisée je n'ai pas la date exacte une
réunion de restitution de ce rapport
auprès des représentants syndicaux de
l'inspection du travail et plus
largement du ministère du Travail pour
qu'on puisse partager un maximum de
choses à ce sujet là je passe sur les
questions qui sont relatives au système
d'information et aux difficultés
d'interconnexion autant de témoignages
dont je sais que vous avez eu
connaissance dans les auditions que que
vous avez menées un seul point que je
veux noter pour dire que sur le
programme 155 les crédits d'intervention
de l'inspection seront en augmentation
18% indépendamment des questions
matérielles que j'ai évoquées c'est
aussi la notre volonté avec l'espoir que
la vacance puisse se résorber et s'il
faut que nous adaptons l'organisation
nous le ferons pour faire en sorte que
cette inspection puisse retrouver sa
pleine efficience et sa planification au
service du contrôle mais aussi du
conseil en matière de droit du travail
voilà madame la Présidente que je
pouvais dire en réponse aux différentes
interventions